I'm very proud and moved to be here
honoring the great achievements of the
great Francis Ford Coppola when you
experience a Coppola production
you not only entertain you've changed
your changed he has given us a string of
hits unprecedented in their complexity
and impact who can forget as 2007
director's cut Cabernet Sauvignon it's
dense richness lightened by hints of
cherry mint and tobacco or the crowning
achievement of the 1991 Rubicon estate
proprietary blend ultra rich and
concentrated with impeccable balance
deep and complex with layers of cedar
currant a nice blackberry sage and
mineral very plush at points yet firmly
tannic and structured Robert Parker gave
it a 90 finding fault finding fault with
the aggressive tannin which he said
cause some astringency in the finish
Parker's a dick
for me this wine is easily a 92 maybe 92
and a half but being honored with the
Irving G Thalberg award for achievement
and winemaking and luxury resorts didn't
happen overnight Francis came to it the
old-fashioned way hard work and making
movies like me now that's how our paths
first crossed friend Francis cast me in
Godfather Part two he told me I was the
star and that there would be a few
flashbacks I mean there'll be a few
flash forwards to Al Pacino who would
play one one of my son's it was my first
Oscar which due to some confusion on the
part of the Academy was for Supporting
Actor anyway I'm very great for the
Francis for that opportunity and even
more grateful for the experience of
being directed by one of the Giants in
the wine business
but but seriously Frances thank you for
the career making break you gave me in
The Godfather - and thank you for your
talent honour and friendship you're an
inspiration and one of my biggest
influences you can see it my acting my
directing my producing and perhaps most
of all in my de niro 2010 estate bottle
pinot cab Shiraz bland anyway I want to
just say Francis I thank you for
everything because I wouldn't be here if
it wasn't for you I love you
you